you and it is foundational sex
differences are not just something that
we made up at one point they are the
building blocks of human civilization
but also the source of so much delight
and mystery and beauty
they would make life worth living
actually in a lot of ways destroy those
and we lose a lot maybe everything
well i've got some exclusive reporting
for you tonight in joe biden's first day
in office the department of homeland
security issued a sweeping directive
calling for a 100-day pause on
deportations we reported that last night
we now have an internal email sent
yesterday to ice officers in texas
that shows how this order was enacted
and we're quoting
as of midnight tonight stop all removals
this includes mexican bus runs charter
flights and commercial removals until
further further notice
all cases are to be considered no
significant likelihood of removal in
foreseeable future
in other words stop sending people here
illegally back to the country of origin
the official goes on to say this and
we're quoting release them all
immediately no sponsor available
is not acceptable any longer the
official notes in the email that he is
just quote the messenger explaining
the directive it wasn't his idea it was
joe biden's
now this email was news to us friday's
memorandum from the bide administration
to halt deportations did not call
for people here illegally to be released
from detention
we made some calls today we learned that
homeland security is currently hammering
out how to enact the memorandum
it does not specifically call for the
instant release of all
migrants in detention so what what was
this memo about
just the result of the complete chaos
that resulted when the incoming
administration on its first
day changed a policy this big without
explaining what it means
chaos we thought the last administration
had a
monopoly on that apparently not